l'une des conséquences inattendues de la
canicule que connaît l'alsace ces
dernières semaines les lacs de montagne
virto vers le phénomène s'était déjà
produit en 2003 autre année caniculaire
stéphane baudry et vincent leignel en
chercher à comprendre les raisons de ce
changement de couleur regarder une au
vert lagon au sommet des vosges drôle de
surprise pour les randonneurs qui arrive
toshirô trid ces derniers jours et ce
n'est pas le seul lac à avoir viré de
couleur dans le secteur j'ai constaté
ceci sur les quatre barrages de la
flèche il ya deux semaines donc à
commencer par le four l'est le vert
alten bayer le chiffre trith et le for
less suite à un orage s'il a retrouvé sa
couleur naturelle
alors pour expliquer ce phénomène et
s'assurer que l'eau ne présentent pas de
danger le service des rivières et
barrages du conseil départemental
multiplie les analyses et prélèvements
d'eau qu'on a réalisé des analyses qui
sont réalisés par le laboratoire
départemental ont pour but de vérifier
qu'il n'ya pas de pollution accidentelle
ou importante
de l'eau a pour informer la population
de la situation
si cette couleur étrange n'est pas le
fait d'une pollution alors l'explication
se trouve peut-être au bout du
thermomètre
la canicule a fait grimper la
température des lacs au dessus de 20
degrés température idéale pour une
multiplication exponentielle de
cyanobactéries des bactéries dont la
concentration pourrait suffire à
modifier la couleur du lac erie
cyanobactéries sont vertes d'aspe verte
qu'un photosynthèse en fait qui se crée
grâce à ces bactéries et les
températures actuelles depuis quelques
jours on a des températures très élevées
font que ces bactéries se sentent bien
et bon peut-être s'est développé un
petit peu plus effectivement mais si
vous voulez profiter de ce spectacle
insolite dépêchez-vous de monter car un
simple orage suffira à faire baisser la
température de l'eau et les bactéries
disparaîtront aussi vite qu'elles sont
apparues et il sera peut-être déjà